[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález hoy ocupa
nuestra agenda la crisis del medio
ambiente el panel intergubernamental
sobre el cambio climático ipcc que hace
parte de la organización de naciones
unidas publicó recientemente la tercera
parte de su sexto informe sobre la
reducción del calentamiento global el
pico de emisiones debe alcanzarse en un
plazo de tres años para mantener el
umbral considerado como sostenible de 15
grados de calentamiento pero la falta de
estrategia la falta de voluntad política
y también la conciencia ciudadana entre
otros aspectos no han permitido que
lleguemos a esa meta el informe del que
estamos hablando y del que estaremos
hablando en el programa de hoy es el
tercero de una gran investigación
presentada en tres reportes diferentes
el primero de ellos estaba enfocado en
especificar y profundizar las causas del
calentamiento global el segundo que fue
entregado el pasado mes de agosto habló
sobre los efectos del cambio climático y
la capacidad de la humanidad para
adaptarse a este tipo de cambios y
finalmente este el informe hace
propuestas para reducir las emisiones
las alertas ya están dadas y las
necesidades pues son más que evidentes
ahora hay que poner todo esto en marcha
que nos dice entonces este tercer
informe a grandes rasgos les hacemos un
resumen rápido algunos de los puntos
destacados este documento plantea la
necesidad de ser más rápidos a la hora
de poner en marcha los programas para
alcanzar esta meta es ahora o nunca
básicamente eso es lo que dice habla
también de esa difícil relación que hay
entre la necesidad de tener crecimiento
económico sostenido y el aumento de las
emisiones es prácticamente directamente
proporcional porque el aumento económico
el aumento de la sostenibilidad
económica pues va relacionado con el
aumento de las emisiones como crecer sin
contaminar es una gran pregunta que se
la podremos plantear a nuestros
analistas invitados el documento también
destaca que las energías limpias son
ahora un poco más asequibles y también
invita a gastar más en inversiones para
crear programas que lleven a
contrarrestar el cambio climático
el desafío es global la responsabilidad
es absolutamente de todos pero son las
autoridades de esta generación quienes
tienen el poder para poner en marcha
este tipo de estrategias que permitan
entonces sostener la economía mantener
la calidad de vida pero eso sí emitir
menos gases contaminantes a la atmósfera
no es fácil pero poco a poco se nos está
acabando el tiempo ya tenemos el tiempo
en contra entonces debemos hacerlo lo
antes posible veamos más detalles en el
siguiente reportaje
un hallazgo alarmante la tierra puede
aumentar de temperatura 32 grados para
2100 si no se toman medidas urgentes así
lo determinó el informe del grupo de
expertos sobre cambio climático de
naciones unidas cuyas previsiones son
las más pesimistas hasta ahora aunque
dice que el planeta aún puede corregir
el rumbo en la cob 26 en glasgow los
países reafirmaron los compromisos
climáticos de la cumbre de parís para no
superar el calentamiento global por
encima de 1,5 grados sin embargo la
perspectiva es mucho más grave estamos
en un camino hacia el calentamiento
global de más del doble del límite de
1,5 grados acordado en parís algunos
líderes gubernamentales y empresariales
están diciendo una cosa pero haciendo
otra en pocas palabras están mintiendo y
los resultados serán catastróficos esta
es una emergencia climática los
científicos del clima advierten que ya
estamos peligrosamente cerca de punto de
inflexión que podrían conducir a
impactos climáticos en cascada e
irreversible esas
para alcanzar el objetivo y evitar un
desastre mayor las emisiones netas
globales deberán reducirse un 43 por
ciento para 2030
4 en 2050 unos datos que son alcanzables
si se adoptan medidas urgentes y el
informe dice que el mundo aún está a
tiempo el gran mensaje que tenemos que
saber es que las actividades humanas nos
metieron en este problema y que la
acción humana puede volver a sacarnos de
él y creo que este es el mensaje
esperanzador que tratamos de transmitir
en este informe no está todo perdido
realmente tenemos la oportunidad de
hacer algo la apuesta por la energía
solar y eólica la restauración de los
bosques el cambio de dieta y la renuncia
a los combustibles fósiles están entre
las soluciones que proponen los expertos
en cualquier caso el futuro del planeta
sigue estando en manos de los líderes de
esta generación
bueno pues así es cómo está el panorama
el informe es muy claro en cuanto a las
sugerencias de lo que debemos hacer
vamos a analizarlo entonces en esta
edición del debate de france 24 para
conversar sobre este tema hemos invitado
a natalia al deber ella es directora de
the climate reality project américa
latina está en la ciudad de cartagena en
colombia y en la ciudad de panamá está
con nosotros gustavo manes él es
coordinador de cambio climático para
américa latina y el caribe del programa
de la o no para el medio ambiente
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
pueden participar en este debate con
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas lo
pueden hacer a través de las redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter también estamos
como france24
y santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 los invito para que dejen
todas sus preguntas y comentarios sobre
este tema comienza entonces dándole la
bienvenida a natalia en el norte de
colombia en la ciudad de cartagena
natalia gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa y comienzo por el punto
clave de este debate y de este informe
que es la necesidad de actuar rápido
pero que tanta voluntad política y que
tanta voluntad ciudadana hay en los
diferentes países y bueno por lo menos
en la región de américa latina para
desarrollar estos planes que ya muchos
están estipulados para poder empezar a
revertir las emisiones de gases
contaminantes en la atmósfera
hola santiago muchas gracias por la
invitación y por hablar de este tema tan
importante en los medios masivos una de
las enseñanzas de este reporte es que la
participación ciudadana si funciona y
que a partir de una mejor gobernanza
climática hemos avanzado mucho para
manejar y mitigar el cambio climático si
bien nos falta un espacio grande por
avanzar lo que sabemos es que entre más
participación juvenil de pueblos
comunitarios de sociedad civil exista
para presionar a los tomadores de
decisión más y más rápido vamos a
avanzar la mitigación del cambio
climático la adaptación y el desarrollo
están ligados completamente a la forma
en la que decidamos crecer y generar
empleos marca que tanto vamos vamos a
emitir gases de efecto invernadero año
con año y por lo tanto dan forma a los
desafíos de oportunidades de mitigación
hoy vemos movimientos climáticos en todo
el mundo principalmente liderados por
las juventudes y que cada vez están
participando más los los actores
subnacionales y no estatales en la
política climática y pues bueno hace
falta mucho más pero claro que importa
gustado ahora le doy la bienvenida a
usted al programa desde ciudad de panamá
allí en la capital panameña gracias por
estar con nosotros por estar con
nosotros aquí en el debate de france 24
y la misma pregunta como punto de
partida la rapidez que especifican estos
informes la necesidad de actuar rápido
porque tanta voluntad política y que
tanta voluntad ciudadana hay para
efectuar estos planes para poder cumplir
las metas
gracias a santiago un placer
definitivamente hay un sentido de
urgencia porque nos queda muy poco
tiempo
para que esta concentración de gases de
efecto invernadero sobre todo c 2 pero
también metano no nos cause una
disfunción
masiva en en toda nuestra economía en
toda nuestra forma de vida de nuestra
agricultura en nuestras ciudades el
aumento del nivel del mar esos esos
fenómenos climatológicos que pueden
arrasar con cultivos que pueden arrasar
con infraestructura pública etcétera no
y sobre todo lo que se intenta es evitar
evitar también ese calentamiento del
permafrost e ese es el hielo que está
congelado en siberia que si se libera
todo el metano que haya acumulado ahí
puede causar un digamos un aumento de la
temperatura y unos efectos en cascada
que verdaderamente estamos hablando de
película de hollywood colapso lógica
prácticamente entonces para llegar allí
hay que cambiar la forma en la que
producimos la forma en la que consumimos
hay que dejar
dejar de generar con carbón con petróleo
hay que dejar de explorar
estas fuentes fósiles no y
desafortunadamente en todo el mundo lo
que estamos viendo es que es esa
tendencia es todavía el aumento blanco
de estos combustibles fósiles entonces
de ahí ese mensaje de urgencia del
informe
gustado continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa de acuerdo a lo que
usted nos dice y también aparte del
informe aunque los países cumplan con
los compromisos actuales con respecto a
la reducción de emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero lo más probable es
que sea muy difícil evitar el
calentamiento global y que se supere
fácilmente esa cifra de 15 grados es muy
difícil lograrlo esto es por la
evolución normal de la tierra y por el
desgaste que ya tiene que le da a la
humanidad al uso de los recursos que
tiene o es a una temperatura a la que
vamos a llegar a la que nos vamos a
tener que acostumbrar y a partir de ahí
ver que otros mecanismos creamos para
evitar que siga aumentando a partir de
esa temperatura es para aclarar ese
punto de este informe
mira ahora mismo estamos en un
calentamiento de
11 grados
y lo que los científicos nos están
diciendo es que más allá de 115 grados
es donde empiezan estos fenómenos en
cascada que hacen verdaderamente
muy insostenible vivir en el planeta
tierra
no solamente para los seres humanos sino
para todas las especies
entonces lo que también nos está
diciendo el informe es que las
tecnologías para reducir esas emisiones
y ya se las energías renovables para
producir electricidad la movilidad
eléctrica oa través del hidrógeno para
sistemas de transporte unos sistemas de
uso de la tierra
parar la deforestación de una
agricultura agricultura sostenible
todos estos existen y lo que estamos
viendo lo que nos está diciendo también
te informa es que los costos de
implementar todas estas tecnologías no
solamente están decreciendo de una
manera dramática sino que están siendo
más competitivos que aquellas
alternativas por ejemplo de los fósiles
no entonces la cuestión es que es
factible
técnica financieramente llegar a ese
límite de unos 5 grados y no superarlo
si recuerdo eso es la parte positiva del
informe
la parte negativa que nos está diciendo
un informe es atención porque para hacer
eso hay que empezar hoy no hay que
hacerlo mañana no hay que retrasarlo más
no hay que decir oye mira que pues yo
voy a seguir fumando hasta que me pase
algo no tú tienes que dejar de fumar hoy
mismo para evitar que tengas cáncer de
aquí un año dos años o tres años
entonces ese es el mensaje y la la
ventana de oportunidad todavía está
abierta pero hay que tomar acción ya si
el informe es un poco angustiante en ese
sentido porque prácticamente ayer ya es
tarde para empezar a tomar acciones para
poder revertir esta situación y natalia
uno de los puntos más difíciles y tal
vez el balance más complicado para
encontrar es ese balance entre mantener
el crecimiento económico sobre todo
cuando la humanidad está saliendo de una
pandemia que todavía existe la
emergencia sanitaria en muchos países y
se mantiene activa pero estamos
comenzando a reactivar económicamente el
planeta cuando hay una crisis por
ejemplo en europa una crisis energética
de las consecuencias de la guerra en
ucrania y cuando se busca reducir
emisiones este balance es muy difícil
pero gustado ya nos dice que los costos
de implementar nueva tecnología y
energías alternativas están siendo cada
vez más competitivos pero necesitamos
que eso sea más rápido para poder llegar
a ese balance cómo lograrlo
pues tiene mucho que ver con la
educación santiago si las soluciones
están ahí en la mano son costo
eficientes
y ya han sido probadas durante décadas
lo que hace falta es que los tomadores
de decisión las conozcan mucho mejor que
haya más flujos financieros que les
permitan invertir hoy en las soluciones
y también que hay una masa crítica de
ciudadanos y ciudadanas que estén
pidiendo esas soluciones y recordemos
que lo que nos tiene también en este
problema son dinámicas de poder que
tienen muchos países con la industria de
los combustibles fósiles y de la
movilidad individual con automóviles
también de combustión interna esto no es
un sistema político y de poder y
económico del que tenemos que salir de
manera urgente entonces la forma para
resolverlo es que haya mayor cooperación
internacional que permita la transición
a energías renovables a mayor innovación
a poder compartir tecnología y mejores
prácticas
y también que las poblaciones en el
mundo en desarrollo puedan conocer mejor
cómo medir las emisiones cómo medir las
reducciones por sus por ejemplo
ecosistemas y también empezar a sacar
ese dióxido de carbono de la atmósfera y
que una parte importante del informe
también es cómo reducir esas emisiones
desde la demanda santiago aquí tenemos
mucho poder los consumidores cómo nos
movemos que con qué comemos que
compramos va a afectar y cómo va a
afectar muchísimo en las emisiones así
que lo que tenemos que hacer es mayor
educación y empezar a tomar acción desde
el financiamiento de infraestructura
a gran escala educación punto importante
ya vamos a hablar del tema alimenticio
de la parte agrícola y de lo que comemos
nosotros porque también tiene hay un
componente importante en la generación
de estos gases continúo con usted
natalia también para hacer la ronda a la
inversa y porque sigo por el mismo punto
que venimos conversando y es esto uno de
todos estos este comentario de
hacer más inversiones promover
diferentes proyectos en la sociedad
educar y uno oye que esto tal vez pueda
hacer pero para los países que tienen
una capacidad económica china japón eeuu
la unión europea rusia que son países
que tienen la posibilidad económica para
poder poner en práctica y en marcha
todos estos planes que hay de los países
menos desarrollados de los países que no
tienen ni siquiera un proceso de
industrialización terminado y ya les
toca saltar a otra generación a otra a
otra forma de producción cuando ni
siquiera han logrado volverse países
completamente industrializados que se
los puede decir a ellos o como ayudarlos
bueno un uno algo que encontró muy
interesante este reporte es que las
políticas que están enfocadas en la
equidad y la erradicación de la pobreza
son más aceptadas por la población
entonces no hay no hay que pasar por ese
proceso de industrialización que provoca
daños en la salud que provoca inequidad
que provoca injusticia en los países en
desarrollo tenemos mucho esos problemas
y lo que queremos justamente es eliminar
esto con la acción climática también
podemos equilibrar la balanza de la
injusticia y la entidad de nuestros
países como lo estamos haciendo con el
programa caminos a carbón neutral en
clamar 'reality' educando a las personas
para que conozcamos de qué manera
podemos jalar esas inversiones en
nuestros países no tenemos que pasar por
una industrialización que nos hace daño
podemos hacer ese salto tecnológico y
también ambiental porque bueno esa es la
demanda y es la invitación que nos hace
el reporte y las buenas noticias también
no como ver que en las áreas urbanas es
dónde más
están generando las emisiones de gases
de efecto invernadero que podemos poner
techos y fachadas verdes parques de
espacios abiertos gestión de bosques
humedales urbanos gestión de agua diseño
de ríos también urbanos los vehículos
eléctricos movilidad accesible para
todas las personas es un modelo que
queremos la mayoría de las personas y
que va a ayudar a los problemas también
la inequidad en los países en desarrollo
así que en realidad la acción climática
y es tan urgencia es una buena noticia
para las personas en este lado del mundo
sin duda lo es gustado y le hago la
misma pregunta me parece un tema
importante porque si en algo se
caracteriza la humanidad es que no es
equitativa en ningún tipo de aspecto
incluso en este tema de tratar de salvar
el planeta y de combatir el efecto de
los gases contaminantes en la atmósfera
tampoco somos equitativos como generar
equidad entre los países entre la
oportunidad que todos puedan implementar
igualmente en soluciones de acuerdo a
las realidades de cada uno de estas
naciones
bueno la la equidad tiene un punto de
partida que es básicamente que todos
estamos compartiendo un ecosistema y que
la atmósfera pues es solamente una
pueden haber muchas fronteras pero
allegri que respiramos es el mismo y de
ahí que todos tengamos nuestro granito a
aportar para reducir esas emisiones para
adaptarnos al cambio climático
obviamente hay un tema aquí de
responsabilidad histórica y el acuerdo
de parís de cambio climático las
negociaciones climáticas desde hace
muchos años lo reflejan así no todos
tienen que construir en base a sus
responsabilidades históricas y se le
tiene que pedir más compromiso a
aquellos países que históricamente han
contribuido más pero lo cierto es que
cuando nos podemos analizarlo es como si
tuviéramos no sé una sola habitación de
diez metros cuadrados y allá estoy mi
colega rico con su hijo y está estoy yo
pobre con mi hijo y estamos los dos
fumando y el aire si los dos jugamos al
mismo
lo vamos a contaminar y que se va a
respirar ese aire contaminado son
nuestros hijos o sea que todos vamos a
subir a sufrir las consecuencias pero
ahí sí y el acuerdo de parís habla de
mecanismos financieros habla de aumentar
en la contribución financiera de los
países desarrollados para que los países
en desarrollo pongan en marcha
soluciones
amigables amigables con el clima y que
les saquen de este modelo para no
repetir ese camino que
desafortunadamente la ha llevado a la
situación que tenemos ahora mismo la
cuestión está ahondar más en eso pero no
esperar a que nos llegue la plata del
cielo porque si hacemos este tipo de
inversiones es que nos vamos a ahorrar
plata y vamos a crear más empleos y a
mover en más rápidamente nuestra
economía o sea que no hay que esperarse
recibir plata para tomar este tipo de
acciones
gustado continúo con ustedes usted está
mencionando el acuerdo de país de parís
firmado en 2015 diferentes países
fueron allí firmantes vimos la
controversia que hubo con eeuu es un
acuerdo que no es vinculante que tanto
avanzado este acuerdo que tanto han
avanzado los países firmantes y este
aspecto es a esa línea de no vinculante
que tanto le permite a los países
simplemente decir yo puedo avanzar hasta
acá o no quiero avanzar o que tanto los
libera de ese compromiso ante la
comunidad internacional
bueno el acuerdo de parís fue muy
difícil de conseguir se tuvieron que
romper muchas dinámicas negativas
con la contraparte de que el acuerdo de
parís pues es un enfoque digamos de
abajo de arriba los países presentan sus
compromisos nacionales las llamadas
contribuciones determinadas
nacionalmente
qué es su visión de cómo pueden llegar a
ese objetivo de 15 grados pero como has
dicho tú no es obligatorio no tienes a
una policía detrás de ti que va a estar
persiguiendo te si no cumples el acuerdo
no pero lo que sí que estamos viendo es
que distintas economías del mundo están
poniendo o están vinculando
temas comerciales con sus emisiones la
famosa huella de carbono si en producir
no según metal acero en mi país tiene
esta huella de carbono cuando yo lo
intento exportar por ejemplo en la unión
europea' voy a tener que pagar este
impuesto
a la importación europea porque he
estado contaminando mucho con productos
son estables o agrícolas etcétera z así
que vamos a ver a futuro pues este tipo
de penalizaciones creo yo no porque este
tipo de enfoques van a ir más adelante
claro quien más contamine pues más paga
impuestos por el daño ecológico que está
haciendo natalia en la ciudad de
cartagena en colombia me salgo un poco
este informe para preguntarle por un
tema de actualidad que puede estar
relacionado con con esta problemática
ambiental y es la coyuntura en la que
está la unión europea en este momento
que quiere determinar el suministro de
gas y el carbón
procedente de rusia por los temas
políticos que los está involucrando a
las dos partes y por la invasión en
ucrania esta coyuntura puede ser un
momento para que juegue a favor para que
europa dé un salto grande en esta
transformación energética para que
acelere el paso para cambiar muchas de
sus antiguas costumbres de producción
energética y que contaminaban cree usted
que es una oportunidad histórica
digámoslo así para la unión europea para
dar ese
sin duda así como la fue la pandemia del
cob y 19 que permitió
visibilizar la forma en la que podíamos
cambiar rápidamente de hacerla la forma
en la que hacemos las cosas esta crisis
permite a europa acelerar su transición
energética hacia fuentes renovables hay
otra vía que puede ir a comprar ese gas
ese petróleo en otros lugares pero pero
pero puede y ya está en la mesa que no
estaba antes de esta crisis la
posibilidad de avanzar más rápido y
también de nuevo pone
a visibilizar la importancia de que las
personas empecemos a tomar más acción si
empezamos a reducir también desde la
demanda la
el consumo de gas y de combustibles en
esta parte de europa
los gobiernos tendrán menos presión para
comprarla y vayan a hacerle un informe
hace algunas semanas de la agencia
internacional de energía con 10 puntos
y salir de la necesidad de comprar este
gas natural de rusia hay muchas
oportunidades hay muchas formas de
empezar
a cambiar no solamente pues porque eso
es un gobierno problemático sino que
también pues sin duda esta crisis nos
abre la oportunidad atrás a transitar de
forma mucho más rápida pero sin duda
alguna en algunos momentos en la crisis
está precisamente la oportunidad natalia
en cierro este paréntesis que tiene que
ver con la actualidad mundial y retomo
este informe y hablo de las energías
alternativas que ustedes han venido
mencionando en sus intervenciones siguen
siendo costosas pero pero cada vez es
posible acceder a más y
mejores precios
a aparatos de energía solar o eólica
para poder generar energía que tanto se
ha avanzado al respecto a natalia sé que
china lidera el tema de la energía solar
pero es un país enorme súper poblado que
hay de la región de américa latina como
estamos avanzando en la región hacia
estas energías renovables y alternativas
para primero decir que las energías
renovables ya son virtualmente más
baratas de producir en todo el mundo
porque tienen un modelo de producción
muy distinto a los combustibles fósiles
cada panel solar extra que ponemos
reduce el costo de un watt de consumo
extra y lo que ocurre al revés en el
petróleo no cada barril de petróleo que
sacó de un pozo pues me va a dar menos
rendimiento entonces tanto el modelo
como los costos y que también nos dice
este reporte ha disminuido muchísimo y
nos permite avanzar mucho más rápido lo
que sucede es que todavía hay más
inversión en los combustibles fósiles
imagínate que en la inversión para
mitigar y adaptarnos al cambio climático
todavía hay estás estas estructuras
políticas y de poder alrededor de los
combustibles fósiles que han moldeado
una parte importante de la civilización
moderna que todavía no quieren escapar
si todavía no quieren salir y no lo van
a hacer de forma fácil a menos que haya
una exigencia pública en américa latina
tenemos mercados muy grandes de energías
renovables en méxico hasta hace unos
años fueron de los países pues que más
donde más inversiones hay energías
renovables chile es un ejemplo increíble
que en pocos años ha aumentado de manera
exponencial su producción de energía
solar particularmente uruguay honduras
costa rica argentina en fin hay muchos
países de la región que ya están
empezando a implementar soluciones de
tecnologías renovables porque pues nos
permite tener energía segura que no
contamina el ambiente barata y pues en
el largo plazo va a generar mejores
empleos
américa latina es un por donde estamos
sitiados es un mercado importante para
la generación de energías renovables y
que si empezamos a adaptarnos y si
empezamos
a traer los trabajos y entrenar a las
personas en este tipo de tecnologías
podemos ver que esa innovación para
traer más empleos mayor equidad y
bienestar ha gustado su opinión sobre
este tema la región de américa latina en
torno al desarrollo de energías
alternativas y sobre todo políticas por
parte de los gobiernos que casi siempre
están muy conectados con el empresariado
con el sector productor de cada uno de
los países es una relación muy estrecha
en la mayoría de países latinoamericanos
ha habido una buena articulación como lo
ve usted
bueno está el estado presente y el
estado que deseamos todos el estado
presente pues tenemos una región
pues que se ha caracterizado por obtener
una matriz de generación bastante limpia
sobre todo gracias a las grandes presas
no y el sector hidro
y que bueno pues eso nos ha mantenido
con una posición cómoda pero digamos que
con el cambio climático el sector hidro
por esas variaciones y sus fluctuaciones
en el caudal de los ríos en los
regímenes de lluvias pues va a estar
afectado todavía en muchos estudios que
no saben bien bien cómo precisamente
pero lo que está claro es que no vamos a
tener esa gran generación eléctrica que
teníamos y que de hecho ya muchos países
están unido a esto y unido también a un
aumento de la demanda del consumo
energético etcétera pues se están
poniendo mayores capacidades en sus
sistemas y muchas gracias estas
capacidades pues sí podrían ser como en
el caso de chile como decía natalia no
como también en el caso de brasil que
también hemos visto mucho crecimiento de
las renovables eso hace unos años en
méxico
el potencial está ahí pero que estamos
viendo que este espacio no está tomando
el gas natural con
unas emisiones pues sí que es cierto
menores que las del carbón pero todavía
con unas emisiones importantes y lo que
es más peligroso esto nos está enrocando
enquistando en un sistema de los fósiles
de los cuales pues se va a hacer mucho
más difícil salir pero dicho esto el
estado deseado es verdaderamente
capitalizar en todo ese grandísimo
potencial que tenemos en américa latina
y el caribe si tengo un colega mío ex
banco interamericano de desarrollo que
dice que américa latina y el caribe es
la arabia saudita de las renovables
tenemos uno de los potenciales más
grandes del mundo a nivel solar a nivel
aliento no sé si es cierto algunos
países lo han no están capitalizando
pero todavía nos falta mucho más hay que
aumentar de tres a cuatro veces más el
nivel de inversión en renovables y hay
que parar de invertir en el gas natural
no es una alternativa y no es un poco
gusta o transición me quedan pocos
minutos para terminar el programa pero
le pregunto rápidamente resulta entonces
paradójico que pese a todas estas
advertencias y a la realidad de la que
estamos américa latina le siga apostando
al gas natural porque se debe esta
situación a qué se debe
bueno antes lo habéis mencionado
santiago hay una relación muy estrecha
entre ciertos sectores
productivos energéticos con gobiernos es
un sector pues que se conocen muchos de
los decisores y que tenemos en nuestros
ministerios o bien tienen unos contactos
muy estrechos con un puesto en el sector
de los fósiles o bien vienen
directamente de ese sector y estos
lobbies pues son muy fuertes y
definitivamente hay que hacer un
esfuerzo mucho más grande para
digamos cerrar ese vacío que existe ese
esa brecha que hay todavía en el
financiamiento climático
a pesar de que sabemos que son
inversiones mucho más rentables
todavía nos falta ver a la banca
comercial metiéndose a fondo en estos
proyectos claro me quedan ya minutos
para poder cerrar el programa quiero que
hagamos las conclusiones comienzo con
natalia conclusiones natalia no tenemos
bola de cristal pero que puede suceder
hacia donde nos estamos encaminando con
estas alertas que nos han dado a través
de estos informes y la realidad que ya
estamos viviendo porque es evidente el
cambio climático es evidente en la
actualidad hacia donde nos enredamos qué
va a suceder con el planeta qué va a
suceder con nosotros si los países no
aumentan su ambición para reducir las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y llegar al pico en
2025 el panorama es muy desalentador
crisis de emigración falta de alimentos
sequías en todo el mundo nos enfrentamos
a un escenario por la supervivencia pero
por otro lado también nos dice este
mismo reporte que la participación
ciudadana si ha tenido un efecto en las
políticas y que las políticas han tenido
un efecto en la implementación de
soluciones y que las que las tecnologías
que tenemos a la mano para enfrentar el
cambio climático hoy ya son costo
eficientes y ya están probadas podemos
hacerlo entonces pues es una invitación
a que participemos con mayor ímpetu en
la toma de decisiones dentro de nuestros
países porque también este es otro
escenario todavía estamos en la
oportunidad de decidir si queremos este
escenario apocalíptico o si queremos
tomar la oportunidad de que nuestra
generación cambie por completo el rumbo
de la historia no solamente salvemos la
vida en el planeta sino que generemos
mayor bienestar para nuestras
comunidades 40 segundos gustavo para su
conclusión adelante
la oportunidad es ahora todas las
decisiones que tomemos tienen que ser
carbono negativas hay que olvidarse de
las inversiones en los fósiles movámonos
hacia las energías renovables movámonos
hacia el transporte limpio cero
emisiones desde el día de hoy porque
como decía natalia nos enfrentamos a un
escenario verdaderamente apocalíptico no
queremos que nuestros hijos que nuestros
nietos vivan ese futuro sería una
ucrania en televisión día tras día vemos
lo estamos a tiempo estamos a tiempo
para poder revertir este daño climático
que hemos provocado gustavo natalia les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros haber analizado este informe
del ipcc para nuestra audiencia de
france 24 américa latina' quiero
agradecerles a ustedes por la sintonía
la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de luís fernando montes y la
producción de invitados a cargo de tania
herrera ustedes pueden seguir con la
programación de france 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]